[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey folks
welcome back to the dark horse podcast
live stream
q and a number 80.
were there any questions so many
questions so many questions
a lot of questions questions questions
are good i always feel bad about not
getting to so many of them but it is
what it is it is what it is i used to
hate that phrase
it is what it is yes and you're saying
nothing
that's true yeah that's true okay um
we're gonna start with three questions
from last week
uh which i always do for the for long
time viewers will recognize that i
always do
go back through after we're done and
just pull
just a couple of questions that i
particularly wish we had gotten to it
does not mean that
all the questions we didn't get to uh
were judged unworthy not at all but
these were ones that these were
definitely worthy yeah exactly and this
first one actually is not a question but
just a statement i wish that more
scientists
it's been a long week has been i'm going
to start over
i wish more scientists today would do
what darwin did
basically steal man all arguments
against his theory and address them all
before going public with his then
extremely anti-fragile theory
i mean all i can say is uh
beautifully said except use the word
hypothesis and you'll be golden
yeah at that it is a theory now yep um
but it was not them
yep yeah um which
you know i mean that that's actually
part of what confuses people right like
the facts don't change but our and
our our certainty as it increases
changes how we
view it as going from a hypothesis to a
theory a theorist cannot advance a
theory a theorist advances a hypothesis
which with
if it withstands test becomes a theory
right
uh so this question was asked last week
and i wish we'd gotten to it last week
because for all i know this is going on
right now the question says my brother's
wedding is next week
uh it will be a large gathering indoors
how do you feel about the ethics of
large gatherings inside at this time
um i certainly wouldn't arrange one if
especially i mean
actually doesn't at this moment either
hemisphere you could arrange something
outdoors
as it gets more summery here and more
wintry
down south you might you know be in
a bind but i would say i would bend over
backwards
not to gather people indoors spend as
little time in cars as possible if
you're going to be in a car definitely
have the windows down
well that's the thing about indoors as
well right like you know large gathering
indoors
if there's ability to have a cross
breeze that improves the situation
dramatically
yep um
what do you think of the ethics that's
the question ethics well
i i guess what i would say is i think
this is a place where
we do have options especially if your
weather is going to cooperate
and given those options i think it makes
perfect sense to
um gently urge people towards having
gatherings that are safer and if you
know if you're gonna be indoors it's not
like indoors or outdoors it's like
is there a breeze is it a high volume
space yeah very different to be in a
space with eight foot ceilings versus
20-foot ceilings
ceiling fans on doors open one
complete wall open those are very
different spaces so
you know think about them that way it's
not all or nothing yeah for sure
brett i am a 26 year old student in cell
molecular biology with add
any advice on um home labs i've never
done well in school so i do o-chem
experiments arduino and crispr in my
garage crispr
interesting crisper in your garage i
actually
missed that on first read through i i
caught the ochem and arduino but um
um yeah i
um i mean it's such a diverse that's
such a diverse set of things that he
says he does
right sure you know if you're asking for
infrastructure or i'm certainly
i'm certainly an advocate for your doing
arduino and related stuff in your garage
the more you tinker the better
um i am in no position to tell you about
garage crisper as a matter of fact i am
only now learning from your question
that one can do crisper
in their garage um please don't augment
anything with sharp teeth or
pathogenic tendencies um which cuts down
the possibilities
rather a lot it does although this does
get to the place where we just don't
know enough to enhance a critter by
adjusting the spelling of its genes
right so we can't do that
yeah we need selection for that yeah we
need selection for that or at least
we're not we're not good at it yet
yeah we're not going to be for a while
uh i don't know that i have any advice
except
it sounds to me like you found the
answer to your conundrum
and it's great that you've got a garage
in which to deploy these things
okay so this question is from the
discord this week so again for those of
you
joining us newly we have a discord
server available at both of our patreon
same discord server
and each week people who want to pose
questions and they vote and so the the
winner of the discord question
extravaganza every week gets asked and
answered here
humans have modified their environment
in myriad ways many of which are in
tension with the selective pressures we
have evolved under
at some point the mismatch between the
current environment and our ancestral
one will be such that our environmental
modifications are maladaptive
there are many lines of evidence this is
already happening such as mental health
disorders allergies chronic illness and
obesity
as a species are we now less adapted to
our current environment are we just
dealing with a new set of trade-offs
how would you design an experiment to
test for such a hypothesis
and if we are now male adapted to our
environment what should we do about it
so i don't
so i will i will say often i very much
love these discord questions but i think
we need to limit it to just one
so that was like four questions wrapped
up in there um and it's also i mean this
it gets to um very much um sort of one
of the central features
uh that we are addressing in our
forthcoming book it's almost the central
theme
right exactly um to what can we
attribute
uh the remarkable level of illness
across
all domains illness taken sort of sensu
latto you know broadly
in the modern era given that we are
living in a time of extraordinary wealth
and productivity
and is indeed um about um the
the rapidity with which we are changing
our own environments such that we
are um have even though we are
the best at adapting to novel
circumstances of anything on the planet
even we can't keep up with the rate of
change that we ourselves are
producing yeah it is the hyper novelty
the
uh the change of the rate of change that
is making this an unsolvable problem so
it is a huge problem it is one
eventually if we do not extinct
ourselves
we will recognize as one of the great
challenges
and i think it also needs to be said
though that
while it is true that we are massively
unhealthy on so many different
levels simultaneously we are also
doing very well in spite of that ill
health
right so um you know it is a mixed bag
but it's getting worse and worse for us
and the we have to reign in the rate of
change or
where this is going to be our permanent
condition absolutely
i guess just one more thing to say about
that um tying it into what we've been
talking about
on so many of these shows kovid that
increasingly and i don't i don't know
that we've talked about any of these
studies
explicitly at least recently um
but the the bad outcomes from kovid are
almost always tied
to what are being called underlying
conditions also known as comorbidities
and um some of these comorbidities are
entirely under individual's control
and um some of them you know in terms of
diet for instance
um that you know the the the better the
diet that you eat the closer
the closer the more recognizable the
food that you eat is to the organism
from once it came
uh the more likely you are to be healthy
um
many comorbidities um may once have been
about choice or parental choice about
things that happen
in in childhood but you but the adults
no longer have any ability to actually
change
uh what is true about their underlying
physiology um
and they can still improve their lot but
um you know many people
um you know with obesity and diabetes
and such actually can't
simply will that away you know there's
it's not a force of oil issue
but it is a modernity issue that these
are largely
the comorbidities for coven 19 are large
largely
um modern conditions themselves
uh absolutely true i will say
the the bad outcomes
you know death is very conspicuous and
so we rate that
even for people without the
comorbidities there seems to be a lot of
damage associated yes um
so anyway we should file that yep that's
that's true
um it seems like and i cannot point to
the data
but it seems like people who are
fit active spending time in the sun
eating good food not only are more
likely to have better outcomes
but are also more likely to fend it off
in the first place and not get sick
and i'm not i cannot point to the
research on that but i've seen bits and
pieces of that in places yep
um and you know to the degree that even
if it was
five percent of the variability and
outcomes why wouldn't you do it
like why wouldn't you take this
opportunity um to to get that part of
your life in order and
thereafter be you know be healthier and
more productive it's not you know it's
living living well and being active is
not a punishment it actually opens up
the whole world to you
all right first question from the last
hour
do you have thoughts and this is from
someone who's called lefty but not loony
do you have thoughts on conspiratorial
ideology among the right
i was shocked at how quickly right
leaning news veered towards a
multi-state multi-judge multi-election
worker conspiracy
to steal the election from trump i'm
concerned about
the arizona bamboo audit i don't know
what that last thing refers to don't
either
well i can't remember where the aphorism
comes from but there's one that says
something like
um the cure for paranoia is candor
something like that i think we are
seeing conspiratorial
thinking rise on both sides for two
reasons
one we have a very corrupt system in
which conspiracy is a common mode
and so it does not it's not foolish to
wonder whether or not corruption of one
kind or another is driving decision
making and in fact
there are all kinds of questions that
are very hard to answer about why we're
dealing with koba the way we are
that do not lead you immediately to well
is this a simple conflict of interest
is somebody prioritizing their you know
buying of a
a nice yacht over the lives of strangers
is that what's going on because that's
not so unusual and yet
it seems to fit so anyway conspiratorial
thinking
makes sense and part of the problem is
that we've demonized it so people
there's no culture of how to deal with
it how to do it responsibly
um and then the other thing is that the
breakdown of the institutions that are
supposed to sort out what's actually
going on
right the scientific institutions the
courts the
press these things are how we're
supposed to figure out what is true
and the fact that they have all been
captured by somebody who's using
this and that for their own purposes
means that we are left to sort out
what's going on
to our own you know instincts
and no kidding that's going to produce a
lot of low quality
conspiratorial thinking because
effectively you forced people
to a tool kit that's too blunt to do the
job and doesn't have access to the right
information and it leaves them
susceptible to those who want to sell
conspiracy theories in order to buy a
big yacht
right so you know you want to fix this
what you need is
well do you remember what the new york
times used to be we need one of those
right we need some of those we need
several of those but i mean one would be
a
huge start yeah zero being a special
number zero yeah you keep saying there
you go that's the flip side of that we
need at least one place that you can go
and it's not going to make the
information in it true but you need
a newspaper that puts figuring out
what's true
as its highest priority yeah wouldn't
that be something oh man universities
too wouldn't that be great
you mean a university that was
interested in figuring truth seeking
rather than social justice and that
advanced
people on the basis of whether or not
they did a good job of figuring out what
was true irrespective of whether it's
popular that'd be that'd be cool it's
fantasy space yeah
ontario canada gave the first doses of
azs going to be astrazeneca i think
right
now they have banned astrazeneca vaccine
for clotting and are apparently going to
be giving other vaccines for the second
dose
also all vaccines are having their
second doses being delayed to 40 days
instead of 20.
thoughts question mark um
i don't understand why governments to
the degree that the clinical trials were
done
and are accurate on what bases are
governments coming in
with presumably no new data and saying
we're actually just going to
mix it up now well i don't think there
is no new data the first well
the 40 so the the astrazeneca being
being banned for maybe clotting
that's that's the that's the one thing
here that there's new data on but then
oh we'll just we'll just switch in a
second
vaccine for the second dose i don't
think there's any
data on whether or not that's going to
be effective or whether or not you might
be more likely to have an adverse
reaction from getting two different
vaccines
i don't think there's any data on that
please tell me if i'm wrong
and then but specifically i was
referring to the 40 days instead of 20.
now the clinical trials i think
you know like the reason that they're
usually and i thought it was actually
well i don't know about astrazeneca but
for
at least the mrna vaccines i thought it
was two weeks apart
um and 40 days instead of 20 like just
just choosing governmental choice um
to extend the length of time between the
two doses
um seems like why would that choice lie
with the government rather than
with the scientists who developed and
tested the vaccine
well i have no idea how these decisions
are being made yeah i do know that we
are effectively in what i believe is
called phase four
uh which is the ongoing monitoring of
adverse events and things and i would
imagine though i know very little about
how it's actually done that there is a
window you get your first
vaccine dose and then some period of
time passes and you get your next
dose within some window of time not
before such and such a period
and hopefully not after such and such a
period and you think the clinical trials
were done that way
i know it was a window rather than i
don't know that they were but my point
is
in the current environment you would
imagine that there would be
at least some diversity of the period of
time between first and second injection
and that that might indicate actually
you know better outcomes or
less adverse consequences on the other
hand
given how crazy this entire regime seems
to be with respect to dictating protocol
and declaring things safe and all of
that right uh i
couldn't swear that there's something
reasonable like that going on behind the
scenes but
maybe there is yeah
this is just a comment thank you for
continuing these courageous and well
thought out conversations
thank you thank you uh
oh and then same person no different
okay so this is a two-part question
um know it's just a comment and then a
question
by the same person note to anyone
reading this novovax is an american
company and the vaccine is made in the
u.s
i would like to hear your thoughts on
novofax seems to me the unknowns and
risks are primarily concerning the
vector of delivery
it's adenovirus oh no
it's period adenovirus and lipid
nanoparticles so that for adenovirus for
the dna vaccine i think astrazeneca also
uses
uh adenovirus and lipid nanoparticles
for the mrna vaccines
novovax uses neither and has a very high
efficiency is the word here probably
efficacies
um what got auto corrected out here
um i know i don't know anything about
november yes i can't speak to it
specifically i will say i don't
and i don't know what the sorry but i
don't know what the vector of delivery
is that's interesting i'd like to know
i don't feel like the limit of the
concern is the delivery vehicle
nor do you or i think have a concern
about adenovirus
particularly in the case of the dna
vaccines it wasn't
um it wasn't that the adenovirus
delivery mechanism was
was the big issue no i mean yeah
and you know you could say it's a novel
delivery mechanism but the point is it's
a novel
delivery mechanism that is a variation
on a very non-novel theme
right you know diseases that we get sick
with and are not serious
are adenoviruses some of them some
common colds and so
uh there is reason to suspect maybe
that's not such a hazard
on the other hand the
the fact that we don't know what cells
are going to take these things up
and transduce them at what rate
yeah how widely distributed is a concern
that has nothing to do with delivery
mechanism
right and then there's the other
question about the evolutionary paradigm
in which
we are focusing very narrowly on spike
protein
as the antigen and
therefore potentially driving the
evolution of the pathogen creating
escape mutants so there are all kinds of
reasons to be concerned and then there's
a general category of
here's some stuff you haven't thought of
that could be involved
so i was uh
recently contacted by somebody who has
had
a severe like she reports
life destroying adverse reaction a very
healthy person
who has had a vaccination
a rna vaccine
and has having a whole list of
very serious symptoms and she pointed me
uh towards the possible activation
of the ige system which is a weird
system that uh for those of you who are
not immediately
uh do not have the information
immediately brought to mind ige
is the system that mediates allergies
now allergies
are by definition bad for you so why do
we have a system that mediates them well
that system appears to be a system that
deals with pathogens that
we in the first world don't struggle
with anymore so it's a system with
nothing to do
that gets misled into attacking things
like
um like pollen
granola but we don't have a problem with
parasitic worms now interestingly you
could connect this back very easily to
the discussion that we had
in the first part of the program today
because
ivermectin is a treatment for
a class of parasitic worms
the presence of the parasitic worms
appears to
prevent allergies there's very
interesting data on that
the absence of them us having eliminated
this parasite
seems to have created a problem with
allergies and the allergy system may be
over activated in people who are
reacting badly
to the vaccine now i you know i don't
know but i
i i don't know how we're going to end up
having to just tattoo
welcome to complex systems on our
forehead and there's a sort of a welcome
you know pic pick your poison problem
right like you know modernity frees us
of parasitic worms
and hands us allergies and no one saw
that coming you couldn't have seen it
coming
but this has happened in across many
systems and in fact we detail a few
a few in in our forthcoming book um but
you know when you think you have
outwitted selection
and solved a thing that we have always
wanted to solve
uh don't hold your breath if you don't
see the
the other side of the trade off yet you
pretty much by you know guaranteed will
because
selection can see pretty much everything
it may take a while
selection has done a great job of
optimizing all kinds of things that you
don't know
have been optimized and so you see a
hazard over here and you're tempted to
cure it and you trigger the thing over
there that you didn't know was connected
to it
yeah so yeah anyway it's it's uh it's
fascinating but um
yeah it's the fact of it being complex
systems is
is what's so frightening um that people
are playing around with the system as if
they understand how it works and
if there's one thing we can say for sure
it's you don't know how it works because
nobody does
yeah i have a question for you about
what's happening off camera
yeah yeah so um our our smallest cat
uh is chasing bugs on the window screen
i don't know what the chance that she's
going to what are the chances that
window screen is going to hold
um and if it doesn't that she's going to
plummet you know just a story but down
to the concrete below
onto the driveway i think the chances
are very good at holds they're not
nearly good enough
shall i go i don't know zack you want to
just
explain it to moxie tell her that maybe
this isn't a good idea she's very good
at taking instruction
is it yeah it's pretty well um okay the
screen itself
well the screen may not happen it's not
secure yeah
she wants to be in the sun
okay yes it the screen is secure it is
her off label use of this
thing that is insecure yes this screen
not guaranteed for cat use
yeah for cat hunting um
okay next question have you seen the
clip of randy paul taking fauchi to task
for his part in the funding of gain of
research
of gain of gain of function research is
a word missing in here
and the role of the nih why is fauci
still on the coveted team with such
clear conflicts of interest
and given that china are i guess is a
two-part question
um given that china are anti-us
anti-black have no qualms genociding
their own people and they dabble in
genetic hybrids shouldn't the null
hypothesis be that covet is a bioweapon
that cut out before it was ready maybe
that's really two different questions
um i actually haven't seen the clip i
know you have of rand paul taking
faushi to task yep something to say
about it
yeah i mean it's a fascinating clip
rand paul is a doctor so he's well
positioned to do this he didn't have to
be but
he was and fauci is clearly
possessing of some little glossary that
has not been distributed to anybody that
explains why the words he's using
don't have the meaning that they would
obviously seem to have if any normal
person said them
so anyway yeah it's what your definition
of is is
it's yeah it depends well yeah it is
exactly that
um but yeah it's it's fascinating why
we're still listening to fouchy i have
no idea
i have no idea and i think the thing is
the allergy
to trump was so severe that anything
that was viewed as in opposition to
trump has been granted
a kind of license like no normal human
being has and
i don't know how many times i mean look
i thought about digging it up for
today's live stream
but the clip of fouchy
a few weeks ago or a month ago uh
spinning tall tales about how this
virus may have come to humans through an
intermediate that we haven't yet
found i mean it was more fouchy nonsense
as was
his but that's i mean that's this that's
that's not new that's the standard
this has been on the table forever no no
but he recently went about hypothesizing
some new way it could have happened that
would explain why we haven't found any
evidence for it it was just completely
out of thin air no evidence whatsoever
don't look over there look over here
you know never mind the man behind the
curtain stuff and
so the point is how many times would
fauci have to show up
lying or uh
just simply involved in a pathway that
is implicated in some i mean
he's central to the question of why gain
of function research was being
yeah funded during the trump
administration he lied to us about masks
and which we now know because he told us
that that's what he was doing
um yeah i don't know why we're still
listening to him i find it shocking
yeah and um maybe we don't want to
spend much time here but to the question
about whether or not the null hypothesis
the null hypothesis should be that covet
is a bioweapon um
i don't think there's i hear what you're
saying
about what um you know that china can be
described as anti-us
and um i don't know if it can be
described as anti-black but
it's engaged in genocide against some of
its own people um
and they do have capacity um i don't
think that's sufficient to make
bioweapon a null hypothesis
i think that that would that would be um
cheating the same way frankly that the
standard issue virologists have been
cheating by um
trying to subvert the lablet hypothesis
this whole time no it's unparsimonious
and you can actually see it in the way
you've had to phrase the question
because in order for it to be a bio
weapon
created by the chinese there has to have
been an accident
that got it released in a place that
would implicate the chinese
right so you wouldn't release it in
wuhan uh
if this was a bio weapon that wasn't
ready to go so you have to hypothesize a
lab leak on top
of a nefarious purpose no i mean
no you don't it could be a nefarious
purpose that specifically wanted to
implicate
the wave um okay but that's not what the
question sure but i mean but what we're
doing here is
exactly to your point that it's it it
requires a bunch of
epicycles right like it require it
requires a whole bunch of extra
levels of explanation which um by
definition are not the most parsimonious
possibility yeah
and the null should be the most
parsimonious possibility um
you know should given what you lay out
here should this be on the table of of
the possibility should it be among the
list of possible hypotheses yeah
it should be yeah but if you're going to
have that list and i did make an attempt
to in my flow chart from
all those months ago i did attempt to be
exhaustive there were lots of very low
probability things on it
but you would have to include not just a
chinese
bio weapon but you'd have to include the
possibility that somebody else
released it intentionally and they did
so in wuhan in order to implicate the
chinese because people would inevitably
check
those dots so anyway i'm not saying any
of those things are
likely um we haven't seen evidence for
any of them so let's leave them all as
possibilities that must formally be
included in a complete solution set but
for which there is no evidence
yeah next question would you vaccinate
your 13 year old daughter today
um well point one we don't have a 13
year old daughter 0.2
no yeah um we do have a 15 year old son
i would say it is in 17 years who's to
say how youtube is going to view these
things but i would say if we're being
asked hypothetically were we to have a
13 year old daughter i wouldn't i
wouldn't vaccinate her
um especially in light of the
possibility that there's something that
buys
some or all of the benefit of a vaccine
that we know
to be safe in a way that we cannot know
the vaccines to be safe yeah
was your mom vaccinated also what's up
with bill maher
yeah my mom was vaccinated um as her
brett's parents as
are all of the older people whom we know
um and um i think it's wise
i'm glad for it um what's up with bill
maher i mean as far as i can tell
so you know we were obviously there so
we know the protocols they have in place
are extraordinary
they are um and um
so he for those who don't know um he
tested positive so you know he missed i
guess his first
you know his first show in since like
the early 90s
because he's on under um mandatory
quarantine or some such even though he
apparently has no symptoms or very few
um so everyone's being tested like three
times a week i think
and you know very very careful like the
whole scene is super careful but
that rate of testing means that you're
more likely to you know
probably there are a number of people
who were positive for covet at some
point and were asymptomatic the entire
time as opposed to pre-symptomatic
before showing symptoms later
and who just never knew and never
bothered to get tested because they
didn't feel anything and so if you're in
one of these situations like
um like bill maher's team
including him is in where you're getting
tested all the time
any exposure that would have likely been
missed in other cases is going to get
noticed
yeah well to your point here though
so bill maher is in a very unusual
position
the question is how
how much testing is being done to
determine how frequently this happens
because
it's possible that mar is
pre-symptomatic
in which case he will have symptoms and
then we could if
people tend to get symptoms following
vaccination and then getting
coveted anyway then you can know what
the case rate is but
if the assumption is that people with no
symptoms don't have it and we only test
people who do have symptoms
it could be that there's an awful lot of
people getting the vaccine
getting the disease us not figuring it
out which then raises
all of these questions about what is it
that they transmit
in other words do they are they much
more likely to have a variant
the reason that they got sick is that
they had something that the vaccine did
not protect them from are they much more
therefore likely to pass on a
variant that does not uh get full
coverage by
the vaccine so right this you know uh
those who want that question explored
should go back and look at garrett
vandenbosch's uh uh discussion with me
on darkhorse and the other things he's
posted he has an extensive website
and i would just say um these
possibilities are important and
we are very likely to be dealing with
the consequences of not paying attention
and thinking oh we've got the solution
in the vaccine let's get it to everybody
and
we're going to get surprised at how
clever nature is absolutely
um uh according to this lancet article
there's a link that we have not had time
to click on yet large-scale testing of
the astrazeneca vaccine took place in
the uk
brazil and south africa early variants
originate from these countries as well
could there be a correlation there could
be but there's so
it's so complex yeah yes there could be
but that's not saying in any way that
it's likely i have no idea
yeah i'm not going to say likely or
unlikely i'm going to say would there be
a
yes of course there could you know if i
mean well i would say
i would want to look at the pattern
myself and see whether there's something
conspicuous enough
that it seems like not just one of a
million possibilities
and it's you know it may well be so i
would also say
great strength of garrett vandenbosch is
that he
is scrupulous
about laying out the predictions
for his hypothesis that will allow you
to know
uh whether it is accurate and so
anyway uh i i would look through that
lens and figure out whether the patterns
are the ones predicted
you know it could be if he wasn't so
good at what he does
it could be that those things are
predicted by more than one hypothesis
but he is very good at what he does and
he's very careful so
i would i would take a good good close
look at his predictions
i'm pregnant i'm not pregnant
wow i am pregnant and not getting the
covered 19 vaccine
should i be concerned about the section
of vaccinated population becoming silent
carriers and infecting others i've read
the vaccine is not meant to stop
transmission
um yeah it's i think that you know those
of us who aren't vaccinated
including for um you know for reasons
that should be understood
even among those who think pretty much
everyone needs to be vaccinated
yesterday
um which i i believe pregnant women or
you know people who are
um you know you were actually our
pregnant pregnant women are absolutely
in that list
um i've lost my train of thought exactly
how i was phrasing that but
um even people who are
who are basically willing to hate on
people who are not getting vaccinated
will understand that there's some part
of the population that should not be
vaccinated right now for instance if it
would put
the health of your unborn child at risk
and it's absolutely true that for
instance the cdc's
guidance that fully vaccinated people
can now be unmasked indoors
in public spaces with with unvaccinated
people
puts the unvaccinated people at some
greater risk how much greater is it
negligible
maybe is it not negligible also maybe
yeah i would say you are right
to be quite concerned about
the implications of how these things
come together and uh you know
the number one thing that you have is
your ability
to avoid contact yeah right that does
not put you in danger
and it can be obviously very effective
do you think it is plausible that the
coyotes can distinguish between the
urine of wolves and the urine of your
golden retriever it's not a golden
retriever it's a labrador it's a
retriever
so i'll i'll rephrase that using the
correct breed
so i'm not offended by this i had some
golden retriever friends growing up but
uh
brett thinks they're they're lesser dogs
they're gullible they're sweet they are
which is the same thing
okay do you think it is plausible that
coyotes can just distinguish between the
urine of wolves and the urine of your
labrador retriever
does the coyote smell the urine in your
on of your pet and think oh cute people
wolf
what if it were a pit ball um
hold on okay there's three questions you
know they're all the same okay hold on
um i'm gonna read all three of them and
they all
fit together to form a thing
domestication neoteny causes the people
wolf's urine to smell like a wolf pups
maybe wouldn't the presence of wolf pups
signal adult wolves nearby
and are the dna and golden retrievers so
different that the coyotes can tell the
golden retriever is
friendly i can't i can't tell actually
that's supposed to be unusually or
usually friendly because it's
strangely misspelled um but anyway the
question is about um
uh effectively um domesticated dogs
having experienced a form of um and i'm
just gonna
be technical here and say it's
pedomorphic not necessarily neoniati
being a particular mechanism by which
you end up with
um juvenile characteristics persisting
in adult forms
um so things like the floppy ears and
such are um are a pedomorphic character
everyone says neotny
i just can't bring myself to conflate
the two that way
um but um that's that i think there's a
lot of evidence for right the
domesticated dogs
uh reveal some pedomorphisis compared to
um to wild canids and the floppy ears
alone
right yep um but the idea that
the pheromones and the urine would
reveal
um would smell like baby pheromones
or or or scent molecules strikes me as
not quite right that in general with
metamorphosis like you know you have
salamanders
um that um you know for instance there's
species that have facultative
paedomorphosis wherein some
depending on what happens in development
maybe they um develop into the usual
metamorphs they go through metamorphosis
and they move on to land and they lose
the webbing between their
hands and they lose the fin down their
back and they
lose their external gills and start
breathing through their lungs um
and in some in some individuals again
depending on the developmental
environment
um they don't uh move on to land and so
they retain their gills
and their webbing and their and their
racing stripe
their racing fin um but all the rest of
their body like their reproductive stuff
becomes adult
and so it's not that everything in the
system except for reproductive capacity
uh is paedomorphized uh it's that some
things
are basically the better to perform in
the environment in which
um that that created the conditions for
the pitomorphosis
so you know why would the why would the
smell
in fact it would be useful to us as
people who
basically co-evolved with with dogs to
have them retain the baddest ass
smelling urine as possible
you would think precisely to keep away
the wild canaanites to help keep away
the wild canadians
well you got two two evolutionary sides
to this puzzle
right always you've got the domestic dog
and whether
it wants to be detected as a wolf or be
distinct from
a wolf and you've got the
other canids and whether they want to be
able to smell the distinction
well then there's three sides and
there's also the people who co-evolved
with the domestic dogs and what they're
so what the thing that i finished on was
the people
might actually prefer for the domestic
dogs here and to smell like a wolf
because then having um domestic dogs
around
you and your tribe uh would help keep
the wild kids away
could be although i must have struggled
with this
differently we have known for a long
time that it was
quite possible to yip
and howl like a coyote and get coyotes
to respond
what i don't know is whether my doing
that around our house
is going to make it a place that coyotes
will be more interested in visiting
because they could get to know some
coyotes they haven't met yet
or less interested because the territory
is spoken for
and i've been hesitant to do it because
i don't know the answer to that question
um just i mean another observation um
when so we haven't we know the coyotes
are still around but they're not as
around as they were before
um and when they were real when we were
really in the thick of it three four
weeks ago
um you and i both saw three coyotes just
down the down the hill from us
and we watched as one started vocalizing
and if we had not had our eyes on that
wild canid i would have sworn to you it
was a dog yeah this die and then in the
middle of barking it went into a yep and
you could tell that it was a coyote yeah
i've never heard a domestic dog make the
yip that it made in the middle but
at the beginning and the end of this you
know probably 30 second long
vocalization it sounded just like a dog
and i didn't know that they could do
that that's
unusual well let's just say
you do have various pieces of the puzzle
i'm
essentially certain that the human
desire for the pea to smell either like
a wolf or not like a wolf for the
various reasons that humans might prefer
that is going to dominate what the dog
might want in other words
dog succeeds by virtue of the fact that
it serves the interests of the people
and that's why the dogs look the way
they do
and um so anyway that that logic got a
hold
doesn't mean that it's the same
direction everywhere
but my guess would be it's very hard
to beat the
the receptive creatures ability to
distinguish
especially since dogs can tell each
other apart at the individual level
right so they're highly sensitive to
idiosyncrasies
and my guess is the idiosyncrasy is
almost inevitably between domestic dogs
and wild dogs are going to be so large
that yes i would expect everybody is
unconfused by these things
um yeah more or less that's that's what
i'd say
cool love you guys i heard brett say
that the chances of significant life
extension were very low
was aubrey de gray selling me a dream
are you familiar with his work
please answer love you guys been with
you for years
uh yeah aubry was celania
bill goods aubrey has brought good to
the world
but by and large his line
about this is an engineering problem
let's just solve it
is nonsense it can't work
there are lots of engineering problems
that one can specify that are
intractable
this happens to be one for reasons we
know
so let's just say that the
very problem that you want to solve in
this case
has a downside that you will invite if
in fact you solved it and even if aubrey
was right in all of his categories of
things that you have to solve in order
to beat this
there's another one lurking right behind
it right which is
do you really want to have a 20 year old
body with a
90 year old brain right we don't have a
clue how to fix the informational
problem
that comes from having a brain that was
built for 80 years of life
and the fact that you might extend it
indefinitely in other words you'd have
to do a whole lot more forgetting in
order to get that thing to work and we
just don't have a system that works that
way nor would you be a functional person
if your brain
was upgraded to work that way or
downgraded or whatever it would have to
be
and then if you even take those two
critiques
the problem that he says is tractable
isn't even if it was
the brain issue right behind it is
devastating to anything there's no life
that you would want to
live that would be the result of having
solved all of the
mechanistic cellular stuff but then
there's this other problem which is who
knows what pathologies would emerge
if you were able to live to 150. do you
know why we don't know because nobody
ever lives to 150
so the point is selection has had no
ability to clean up
the life after the maximum human
longevity
so therefore what you've got is
basically an invitation to new
pathologies that are liable to be
extreme and
so numerous there's nothing to do
anything about um so
yeah i'm not a fan of the style of
thinking i think it is
a waste of time and money and the reason
is a waste of time and money is that you
could take the same money
and the same time and you could invest
it in extending
average life span rather than maximum
lifespan and we would make great gains
we know that because we already do make
great gains
we've greatly increased maximum
longevity we've
basically extended youth and we could
extend that to more people or do an even
better job of it so
anyway yeah it's a bill of goods and um
i guess there's nothing to be done about
it because
fountains of youth are very attractive
even if they don't exist
and that's where we are
i am taking my first post covered trip
to the canary islands
specifically fuerteventura and lanzarote
this month
any tips on what biodiversity to notice
or appreciate
i i will only speak for myself know
almost nothing about the canary islands
we've never been
um they're small you know what they're
uh the tropical
off the atlantic coast of africa um
i think but spanish um but never having
been
uh i have no idea to what degree any of
their uh presumably
fairly high degree of endemic wildlife
even persists or maybe there's just
nothing maybe it's basically birds and
marine stuff
yeah that'd be my guess yeah um so
the smallness of islands tends to result
in low
uh numbers of species i just don't even
know how big they are also results
in the vulnerability of those species so
things that people will have transported
there
well the smallness and the proximity i
mean like classic right like classic
bird
theory photography island by geography
right um is like the smallest of the
islands and the distance from a source
population the distance from mainlander
the
um are both you know that you make the
islands get smaller
the islands get farther away from uh
from a home population
and um you're less likely to have a lot
of interesting stuff going no no i
wouldn't say that the species number
goes down
endemism is liable to go up with
distance um but any in any case it's
it's likely that on land it may be very
pretty and there may be a few nice
things but
um yeah they seem you know smallish
pretty close to
northwest africa yep but if they haven't
been carefully protected
my guess is on land not so much but
uh if there's marine sanctuary which
they might
offshore and i mean maybe i'm wrong
maybe the canary animals are
yeah i just don't have any idea honestly
marvelous online but
yeah anyway have fun and report back
yeah
uh thank you for the weekly reminder
that not everyone is going batshit crazy
cool uh what is your take on the worries
about prion disease due to the vaccines
oh my god i have not heard that
i don't know i have no idea um prion
disease is
uh as a result of the disease vaccines
oh the vaccines
i've not heard that yeah uh
i think we need to reserve yeah comment
until i heard that
looked at it you know obviously
welcome to complex systems this was on
the list of
possibilities you're intervening
electromagnetically
in an environment you're basically uh
using nanotech to block you know it's
partially endogenous nanotech you're
triggering the immune system to create
antibodies that recognize the spike
protein but nonetheless the
ability to potentially change other
things in the environment so that they
fold differently than they would
otherwise have done
hence the basis of a prion disease is
there yeah
i'd be very curious and potentially
frightened by the discovery that
uh had been observed yeah okay two more
then we'll skip to the
to this hour's questions um both of
these
are comments i am 16 you guys inspired
me to study biology
hell yeah cool welcome to complexes
that's right it's gonna get messy um
i've become oh so this is someone we
know
twitter this is um someone who goes by
self-made woman
on twitter i've become permabanned on
twitter i miss y'all's tweets i feel
like sauron
ripped from the nexus so this is um
a uh a trans woman who i've become
friends with
who is um utterly reasonable in
her understanding of of who she is and
what she
is actually made of and is that why they
banned her i don't know so i'd love to
um i feel like i'm just i'm not going to
use your name here um because you didn't
use it there but um we had an email
conversation a while back um
and you can know you can find my email
on my website anyway but um get back in
touch and tell me why you got banned if
you would
um i don't know what's the reasonability
yeah
exactly that that being trans and not
putting up with the
garbage that the trans rights activists
are trying to force down all of our
throats
was probably it which is obviously
completely unacceptable
yeah let's see we're going to the next
hour's questions
now
for a 60 year old male and 30 year old
female which vaccine
which for a 60 year old male and a 30
year old female which vaccine do you
recommend what are your thoughts
specifically in the johnson johnson
vaccine did you or your son get a
vaccine
thank you well we can't recommend
anything
to you i can say the considerations are
as we've
described them here many times the dna
vaccine has one fewer
reason to worry about it uh which is
that the
the platform is evolutionarily not far
off of something that people confront
all the time and have for
uh for a long time so which is the
johnson johnson
vaccine that she mentions yeah um but
frankly there's reason to be concerned
about all of them even just at the level
of what they do in common
which is produce spike protein that
will have unknown effects on the system
yep
and we are not vaccinated yet
um and neither of our sons is as of
an hour ago i feel i may have had the
equivalent protection it's just begun i
have another dose coming in 48 hours and
then i'm going to keep the up the
maintenance on
on the ivermectin but yeah and i'm gonna
i'm gonna
think on whether or not to do the same
thing all right i'm an amino i'm gonna
have an update yeah
oh boy uh should we try to reclaim the
term eugenics
from those who only say associated with
racist genocide isn't any form of
selection technically an amplification
of desired traits over undesired ones
no i mean that that word is fraught i
mean for
the obvious reasons that you mentioned
but it's just like it's fraught just in
terms of its actual
um formulation too this this
this prefix e u u um means
true or real and um you know the idea
that
people who are doing eugenics are
practicing the real genetics that's
that's
terrible that's not right that's you
know that that pro that it presumes a
misunderstanding of evolution
that there's some best fit that is
universal that change doesn't happen and
it's just it's
totally misleading um and i would say
that you know that prefix actually gets
abused all the time
over in biology space i'm thinking of
the eutherians right there's three
three clades of mammals um the
monotremes the wacky mammals the
platypus and echidnas the metatherians
um middle mammals therium being mammal
which is the marsupials and the
euthyrians the
true mammals which is the placentals
which is us well who named the true
mammals the true mammals it was one of
these true mammals and it's just like it
it over and over betrays the arrogance
and self-centeredness of the people
doing the naming
yeah yeah yeah i would say for so many
reasons
it's not the right term and
you don't want it yeah i mean there are
some terms that i would
yeah there are some terms that i would
try to claw back but not that one
yep yeah doesn't mean we can't have a
reasonable discussion about you know
selection in favor of traits and what it
has to do with sexual attraction for
example
but that's not eugenics that's a normal
biological process not a
attempt to yeah to control it in favor
of the true genes
or something indeed um
in our ancestral environment aren't
families supposed to sleep huddled
together
skin-to-skin are we missing something
important for our health and for family
cohesion
do we sleep on our belly to mimic human
contact
that's interesting um it's really hard
any such universal pronouncement is
going to be tough because there's so
much variation
that you know if you if you were in the
arctic um
probably yeah very much so um if you
are in the you know the amazon there's a
whole lot of hammock sleeping
and mostly mostly you don't sleep next
to other people because it's really
uncomfortable because it's so hot
um that's not the case i will to the
degree that there is any universal
with regard to sleep and proximity to
other human beings
um for humans um it's probably going to
be about babies all right like babies
and mothers
definitely sleep skin-to-skin in pretty
much
i think everyone i'm just gonna say
pretty much because i'm not totally sure
but i think
i think every pre-industrial society oh
yeah
and um and you know there are a lot
there a lot of us who did that with our
own babies even though we live in
you know post-industrial societies and
um it's better for baby
it's less disruptive actually for sleep
of mom
um it's it's just it's just better all
around and you know
and people and it stops at some point if
you have
if you have a strong bond with your kid
um they don't become climate clingy and
demand that you always do the thing that
you were doing in the past yeah
in fact it creates attachment which
creates security which results in
healthy adults yeah um yeah so there are
all kinds of reasons
i would love to know if there is a
definitive review in ancestral
sleeping styles how did people actually
sleep and what does it have to do
how did they manage the parasites that
might accumulate from such a thing
um you know were they sleeping on the
ground i mean
you know sleep was managed in some way
and our
current way of doing it is so novel and
has so many pathologies associated with
it
that at least knowing what people did
and in response to what environments
uh in some sort of systematic way would
be very very useful
yeah but you know for sure sticking your
newborn in a different room and letting
them scream
um as some sort of crazy ham-fisted way
to
teach them to buck up or something like
that's insane well and it comes from
this
crazy mid 20th century
flights of psychological fancy where
people thought that you you know you
were in constant danger of over
loving your children and that causing
them to
yeah that's a scourge yeah anyway that
stuff was all garbage
frankly if there had been anything like
an evolutionary
understanding in psychology at the time
it would have been laughed out of the
room
right children are raised to become
healthy
well-adjusted adults and adults are
built to know you know
how to deploy love to their children and
the idea that you have to inter
intervene in some
counter love right tamp down your love
and you know
steal yourself to listen to your child
in the other room screaming you must not
give in and that's just
nonsense yeah i mean in fact a lot
modern parenting um
has kind of reversed the developmental
stages at which it does the right stuff
so you know early on you want to be in
contact with your baby as much as
possible
and you know either parent both parents
other caregivers aloe parents
um and and attend to their every need
as they as they show that they have them
and
that allows you to much more quickly
than these kids who are like isolated in
rooms as babies
to they they will start these you know
babies who are
who are raised from infancy uh with with
attachment
basically um you know anecdotally we
know for sure
and i've seen in research that those
children are
earlier to explore are more confident
going out
they they know that's that their parents
have their back
and that you know that that we will do
everything possible for them
but that they are also now increasingly
going to be responsible for their own
decisions
they are going to have to clean up their
own messes uh both you know physical and
psychological and social
and that actually creates anti-fragility
and um and awesomeness in in adults
in a way that um letting them scream
when they're babies and then coddling
them more and more and more as they get
older is
um as backwards and produces
a generation that is
that is confused and damaged and frankly
it's not really their fault
yep
thanks to you both and to last week's q
a commenter for the valuable ivermectin
info and deep dive
really dig the long episodes i'm very
curious
about a theory probably a hypothesis
you once mentioned about dog
consciousness being enhanced by
association with us
question mark totally and i must say i
share credit
for that hypothesis with our dog
luckily she does not ask for authorship
on such things no she's very generous
with respect to
authorship um although she's going to be
mad to find out that she's been
diagnosed as a golden retriever
right and when that dog gets mad i've
actually never seen it right it doesn't
happen it doesn't get mad
no okay so
the question is why would i say such a
thing about i'm just curious i'm curious
about a hypothesis you once mentioned
about dog consciousness being enhanced
by association with us
okay so you gotta step into uh heather
and my toolkit
on consciousness which starts from the
premise that consciousness
is most fundamentally about the
so-called inter-subjective space that is
to say the reason that you would evolve
something as clumsy as
consciousness is because it's the only
way to accomplish the trick
of exchanging abstract ideas between two
individuals you have to basically have
an agreement on what you've said
right so that you you know what it is
that you're processing that means
that basically there has to be
a shared space and the point is that
shared space
is inherently about language right
language is the tool that we use to
access the shared space to hand over an
idea to get it parallel processed which
is the reason for consciousness
once you have that consciousness you can
do it in your own mind you can
debate between two possibilities just as
you would between two people
but the point is the more linguistic you
are
the more rendered that shared space
is and the weird thing is that
dogs are pretty much second right you
can make an argument for
certain birds that they can get a large
vocabulary
and i've in fact heard some stories even
last week we heard a story
about a bird that appeared to be able to
put together uh
disjunct words to make new concepts i'd
love to see that demonstrated but anyway
a parrot one of a couple of families in
which you might expect such
such things corporates would be another
rose ravens js
uh but the point is dogs
are weirdly asymmetrical language wise
they can only say a few words mostly
loudly
yes um i can't say any words um but they
can understand a great
uh many words they can have a large
vocabulary of things that they actually
do
they have no productive language but
they have receptive language right
what's more
if you look at our shared consciousness
model it really isn't about language
itself
it is about understanding what the other
person is thinking which language is
by far the most efficient way to do that
and dogs are pretty good at
understanding what we're saying to them
if we're consistent about it
but dogs are really good at figuring out
what we're thinking from other cues too
you know as hunting partners for example
the dog intuits what it is that
the hunter that they are partnered with
wants them to do to facilitate the hunt
because they understand the hunter
because they've done it a bunch of times
and they get used to the pattern the way
people on a soccer field would get used
to what their teammates are going to do
and they would intuit it without anybody
having to say anything
so the point is it is the partnership
between people and dogs that has clearly
made
dogs more conscious than their wild
counterparts
and i would argue more conscious than
even
our closest relatives in many cases
so dogs are a special case because
they've hung out with us for so long and
i
the thing about dogs that you don't
necessarily
intuit is their history of domestication
is longer than
any other critters it's longer and more
intense because it doesn't have anything
with farming it had to do with hunting
and because it had to do with hunting it
goes back some 30 000 years whereas
every other
human partnership with an animal it just
goes back less than 10.
so anyway dogs are special they've been
hanging out with us for a long time and
they have some idea what we're thinking
at this point which is the basic answer
to your question
yay bugs studies have shown monoamines
metabolizing in invertebrates does this
mean they can feel pain or rather this
means they can feel pain right
how would they feel if anything
this is from mary my former student i
don't know if i don't remember she was
your former student as well
i guess if she was she still is you're a
former student right yeah
anyway um just to say that this is this
is someone who does have um
background in um in thinking about this
kind of thing and i don't
know i i didn't know um this
results and i don't know if that means
that they feel pain
i'm not sure i i can totally make that
link but
maybe you gotta drill down on what you
mean by
feel pain right and there's a i'm not
going to fully deploy it
here and now but if i make a circuit
right in which you push a button and a
light goes on and i say this is the
suffering circuit
right does the circuit suffer just
because i've called it that
so the reason that that's relevant is if
you had
a drone that had an alarm on it when an
arm had broken off right is the drone
suffering
it detects that its arm is broken off
okay now if you do that with a spider if
a spider loses its arm
and a signal is sent and in fact one of
the marvelous things
uh when you look at insects that have
come out of the forest
in a tropical environment where you get
a ton of insects at lights which is not
so cool but nonetheless you do get it so
you set up a light trap so
to call to collect right you know not
inherently killing them but just to
observe all these insects that are
attracted to your light you find a lot
of
the tropical insects are missing limbs
they've had a run with something and
they're not
complete right and the
most fascinating thing is that they seem
to have programs that accommodate that
it happens
so regularly and they survive it that a
program that figures out well how do you
locomote when you're missing that leg
right exists in there cool
so detection is valuable well right and
so they must have detected that they're
missing a limb
right and if that were you that
detection would at least involve pain
so do they feel pain but if the you know
if there's a program
to employ at the point that you lose a
limb to make you better off in the world
uh and upon losing a leg as an insect
you just immediately get sealed off
there would in fact be
very little if any benefit to
experiencing pain exactly but then take
it one step farther which is
why would there be any subjective
experience of pain in that creature
at all why would there be any subjective
experience of anything right because the
fact that it's all
automated if it's all automated right
and i don't want to detract from how
sophisticated the automation in
a fly or any other arthropod is it's
amazingly sophisticated but there's no
you don't get any there's nothing
behaviorally they can do there's nothing
they can do to modify their environment
to make them more likely to recover from
the loss of a limb for instance
which is not the case for a salamander
or a human
right then what you know why would
selection have burdened it with
the subjective experience of oh [ __ ]
this hurts right
so i don't want to rule out that they
could or that some rare
insect does while the rest of them don't
right
any of these things are possible but
in order to know what is true what is
worth imagining is true
the question is what does it allow you
to predict that you couldn't predict
without assuming that thing and the
answer as far as i know
is nothing yeah so yeah you know i want
to cautiously say
not clear that they have subjective
experience so the fact that they have
something that plays the role of pain
doesn't mean that they ouch you know it
may not be
in there i like it i like it
um can you
still be an asymptomatic spreading even
after taking ivermectin how does this
work in other diseases for which it's
used
yeah so this is what i was trying to get
at in the first hour i don't know
the answer to that nor do i know
well let's see with regard to the other
diseases for which it's used i don't
know if there's any other respiratory
diseases so you know if it's
if it's blocking like sleeping sickness
and sleeping it's it's used for like
helminthic things
and you know you're not gonna things
that require
a vector right aren't it's not it's not
a relevant question well it's
sort of a relevant question okay because
you can't
transmit presumably and i know nothing
about the life cycle of the particular
worms that cause
river blindness but i believe they have
a second host
so i believe so too well you you cannot
trigger the disease in someone else
absent all of the members of the life
cycle but can you do
your part right in that life cycle
and my guess is going to be based on
what i've seen and i'm completely open
to discovering
that it isn't what i think but my guess
is going to be
highly effective at preventing you from
coming down with the disease without
coming down with the disease you're not
going to transmit it
some people are going to get the disease
at a much reduced level
their rate of transmission is going to
be low because at a comparably reduced
level
to match the degree of disease they have
right exactly
and um that therefore there will not
the number will not be zero but it will
be very close to zero
more importantly though what they pass
on in that case will not be specially
selected right it will not be specially
selected variants because the action
of fiber mechtin on the spike protein is
general more like
innate immunity than it is like adaptive
immunity
so don't know that that's true but that
would be my best guess based on what i
know
next question i am jewish and very
disturbed by what is going on in israel
as well as the anti-semitism on social
media
what are your thoughts indeed
um i will say i'm i'm not jewish but um
that um barry weiss again has produced
some
excellent thinking on this and um
she is uh she's sort of a one of two few
lights
in the darkness here yeah yeah um
yeah i have complex thoughts because you
know i think
uh like many jews and maybe most
especially jews in israel
i have misgivings about the israeli
government and the way it behaves with
respect
to palestinians on the other hand i
recognize
just how dangerous the environment is
and just how
difficult it is to get the palestinians
to the table for
a proper peace agreement and so
there have to be ground rules right
firing rockets at
civilians is intolerable hamas is a
terrorist organization
and you know this is the desired result
is chaos and i think it is far too easy
to wag
one's finger at israel when in fact you
don't have a solution that
works for the predicament in question so
um anyway
i do uh i hope to see
a great breakthrough here but i am
not gonna bend over backwards to make
excuses for people who are
targeting civilians and using other
civilians as a shield and
um yeah absolutely it's insane
um insane and quite despicable and
frankly
uh people who don't recognize that ought
to think harder about the problem
yeah indeed uh do you have thoughts on
biden's
simple rule tweet mask or vax i have not
seen the tweet i had not heard of it but
you can intuit it from the question
um i'm not thrilled that we seem to be
losing nuance
i guess maybe that's just enough like
we've said enough about we've already
answered several questions here
about yeah actually um
saying that even in close spaces um
i don't know i'm not sure i even want to
say anymore yeah
i will just say um
in the context of what we explored in
the first part of
uh today's live stream how the hell can
you turn this
into a simple binary
where you have a choice mask of x
first of all masks are not
fantastic protection the vaccine
is not a secure solution right we have
asked are better than nothing you're not
saying i'm not saying masks are nothing
i must say i think that there is some
nuance that needs to be explored with
respect to masks and
you know it's now we've now been doing
this with masks long enough that we're
in a position to know a lot more than we
did
but but the point is i don't want
i don't want team blue wagging its
[ __ ] finger at people who are
concerned about vaccine hazards i don't
want them
who is joe biden to tell us that you
know it's mask or
vax when joe biden was on the team that
thought we needed to be wearing them
outdoors until
two weeks ago yeah right this the the
fact is these people have burned their
credibility on this yeah i mean the
cdc's recent pronouncement about
if you're fully vaccinated you don't
need to wear masks indoors or out like
how about
how about let's start with what we do
actually know and have known for 14
months now
regardless of your vaccination status if
you're outside and you're any distance
at all from people you don't need to
wear a mask
full stop that what that gets in the way
of though
is the assessment of whether or not you
have a star in your belly or don't
and so as long as we have these rules
and this you know this actually this
this little piece of video that you
showed me that i guess eric your brother
had tweeted yesterday um from um
rachel maddow um basically revealing
that um she's been feeling virtuous for
hating on people who are not wearing
masks outside
yep and she's trying to wrap her mind
around what it would mean not to be able
to assume that somebody without a mask
was a bad person
it's you know
this is the administration of unity
apparently i see
unity i see no i mean i actually see a
lot of evidence that they're trying to
do exactly the opposite that the
divisiveness
um that that even trump spurs will
recognize trump
loved that he helped did he facilitated
that he augmented
but no he did not fully create that
divisiveness
that we all lived four years through um
looks a lot different in the biden
administration
very very different but the divisiveness
and
the the political winds from keeping us
hating each other and looking at scans
at each other is very much alive
and you know for those people who were
so certain
that a win for team blue last november
was going to change that environment
well you were wrong
yeah like this this is just just a a
nightmare scenario in which we are being
divided at every possible turn
yeah and i i must say as long as we're
on the topic of that
matter thing i do feel like it is
you know one hesitates to use the term
proof
but it's as close as you're going to get
to the
revelation of exactly what you were
hypothesizing about
sneetches right as far as i know you
were the first person to say anything
about that
and the sneachness of it was revealed as
maddow is wrestling with the fact that
the rules of the snitch game have now
changed
the good people are now no longer
recognizable by the symbol
that had been agreed upon by the people
with the npr tote bags
and you know and the fact is okay so we
guessed right yes you were doing that
yes you all knew that you were doing it
and now you
you want to you have to you know get
around to
accepting that actually no the good
people are the ones without masks
because they've been vaccinated
i mean okay screw your game you know
yeah it's garbage
yeah it's entirely a social game and
it's antithetical to
a scientific attempt to understand the
world yeah
and it it's anything but we're all in
this together which is what you've been
pretending we're all in this
together and therefore you have an
obligation to do this and to do that
when in fact your advice has been
low quality to begin with and oftentimes
uh simply about finger wagging right
masks outside that was never there was
no evidence ever that that was a good
idea
yeah is there any evidence that the
that hiv emerged from gain of function
research
never seen any i don't i actually i
don't know the history of gain of
function research enough to know if it
even
extends back that far i have no idea i
just i just don't know
um yeah i think i can say there is no
affirmative evidence for that
at all that there was
concern that it might have emerged from
the use of primates in i believe an
early polio vaccination
campaign i believe in fact that bill
hamilton the great evolutionary
biologists who died
of complications from malaria
and somehow an aspirin that lodged
itself weirdly in his
digestive tract i didn't know the
aspirin angle um
that he at the point that he went to our
he was kind of a
um what's the term he was a bit reckless
he was a very
smart good guy we knew we knew him a
little bit but anyway he was a little
bit
reckless and he went to africa and i
think did not take malaria prophylaxis
even though he was going to a place
that had seriously had yeah
um he contracted malaria and it killed
him but
the trip he was on when he went was
actually to investigate that hypothesis
and i have seen reports that whatever he
was looking into didn't pan out and it
so therefore it is assumed that the
hypothesis is false maybe it's even been
conclusively demonstrated to be false
but no i don't think gain of function
research ever played a role it was a
question about
uh monkeys or monkey or primate tissue
uh that may have been used in fact i'm
saying monkey and i can
fin i can finally genetically defend
that but it was almost certainly chimps
that would have been
the source um
this is just a next question is not a
question
mice from jack's lab here's a link live
webinar on their offerings for coveted
related research
may 20th noon 30 eastern daylight 10.
um all right i can source uh
some of those groucho marx glasses with
the nose and yeah
yeah yeah okay
let's get through i don't know four more
questions
uh wanted your thoughts on
merriam-webster changing the definition
of anti-vaxxer i didn't know they had
as the new definition now includes both
of you oh good
wait what love the show especially when
you guys make you the last highlight of
my weekend that's what it says
presumably okay so zach's going to look
at it assuming it doesn't include us
specifically presumably of course
somehow but
it says but uh so it was merriam-webster
zach you can see it
yeah um while you're doing that i'm
going to move to the next one okay zach
we'll come back to it
two x's yeah um in what class
i don't know i don't know the sound is
familiar but i don't quite
anyway in what class did you guys bring
up the periodic emergence of cicadas
any are there books i can read to learn
about similar phenomena in biology can
you recommend any entry texts on
evolutionary dynamics
well we yeah for the final book the
first book that we recommend to everyone
is the selfish gene yep by
by dawkins 1976. um we'll do that after
we answer this question but okay
um and um i don't know you know
a similar phenomenon similar phenomena i
don't
i don't know maybe we should ask john
and dave but i i don't know that's
similar phenomenon
yeah i think similar phenomena are
liable to be on other planets that we
haven't found yet
yeah um where's the pity yeah i don't
know of any similar i mean there are
other
you know jaw-dropping things but
you know that one's special yeah that
one is special okay so zach
our producer has found merriam-webster's
definition of anti-vaxxer and put it on
the screen that's practically on the
ceiling which is why we appear to be
looking at the ceiling now
definition of anti-vaxxer a person who
opposes vaccination or laws that mandate
vaccination
as anti-vaxxers launch a campaign
against a bill that would eliminate
their ability to opt out of required
shots
supporters of the proposal are
delivering more than 21 000 petition
signatures to the office
office of state senator ben allen well i
would say
shame on i mean first of all i'm not
exactly sure why they're defining a term
like anti-vaxxer which is like
you know it's a word
i'm not sure it's a word it's a it's an
epithet in some sense
um but
the question is so i guess i mean i
guess this
the first part of that definition a
person who opposes vaccination
you know under all circumstances
anti-vaxxer
i thought referred to that right and so
the or laws that might so yeah but i
think it's deliberately written
comes well maybe that's it maybe that
maybe it maybe you're arguing it
shouldn't be in the dictionary because
um it is always used as epithet even
though there is some small i
actually don't have any idea how big the
category of people is
who um simply oppose i know they simply
close vaccination i know they exist i've
met some i know some
but um but i don't i don't know i wonder
if it's like you know the actual
alt-right like yes they exist but it's
just this tiny
fringe group i don't know but i
i think the thing that's really
troubling to me is that the way they've
written that it's a mott
and bailey it's both well yeah
think about it a person who opposes
vaccination or
laws that mandate vaccination is that
ever a person who opposes any
law right or right any vaccination or
all right and the point is those are
extremes of a continuum i'd say you're a
freaking
idiot if you don't oppose any
vaccination or if you can say in advance
i approve of any vaccination that comes
down the prank at me and i approve all
laws that mandate any vaccination
what kind of a [ __ ] would have to right
that makes all reasonable people
anti-vaxxers it does whether or not you
fall out where we do on cover 19
vaccinations
that makes every reason a person an
anti-vaccine to be clear
because somebody's going to clip that
right the point is
merriam-webster's definition is written
so that it is
either maximally narrow or maximally
broad
depending upon what mood you're in and
that means
you can use it arbitrarily as a weapon
so
it's like a dictionary as mood ring
dictionary is a bludgeon yeah but uh
true
god damn yeah that is a terrible
definition and given that like
you know as far as i know
merriam-webster they've got one job
yeah i think so they got one job right
right clear definitions
and here what have they done they've
written one boy you could parse that
either way
yep for sure um
okay so i said i'd read like two more
i'm just gonna skip to some that i think
uh
oh here's a follow-up we talked about
synesthesia a while ago
um hi to what or maybe it's not a
follow-up so we talked about synesthesia
a while ago
and you are asking hi to what degree is
occasional synesthesia
synesthesia a useful no start over
hi hello how you doing
pretty good excellent uh to what degree
is occasional synesthesia
useful survival wise for humanity i
the question answer oscar is a
synesthete
um yeah i i think it it is i mean i
think i think
i think two things i think that you know
rare phenotypes
um are valuable because they introduce
uh variability into a system you know
and you know the go-to example for this
um
which i like not just because i'm a
left-hander big because it's an obvious
one
is that across cultures across time as
far as we can tell ten
roughly ten percent of people in any
given population are left-handers
um that right-handedness is always
dominant um but that except in
um in those strange situations um such
as for instance my father grew up in
uh where um left-handedness is
considered a sign of the devil and
you're
you're basically forbidden from from
using your left hand
left-handedness always shows up at this
you know rare persistent level
and it's it provides value um
in you know if you had everyone being
right-handed then there are going to be
situations where you don't have the
optimal person for the job
and synesthesia which allows you to
basically cross the usual sensory
boundaries i feel like could have
a similar similar virtue so there are
two things buried in here
one is the specific things that a
synesthete encounters or
perceives may be of value themselves
yes and then there's also so that i feel
is likely
sometimes it will be true um but
there is also the question of
slight diversity
in pathway just simply results in a
population that sees more stuff
and so even if synesthesia had no direct
perceptual value the fact of some people
having had the developmental experience
of not experiencing things on the same
channel that others did
would cause them to be somewhat
differently wired in a way that's often
useful and i would point out color
blindness
also uh shows absolutely
periodic utility yeah it is it's not
persistent um
you know because there's such a strong
genetic component it's not at a stable
rate across populations
in the same way but it is but it is i
don't know of any populations in which
it is totally absent
right and the red green color blindness
uh
i believe turns out to be adaptive
and in modern circumstances or
relatively modern circumstances people
may know
that colorblind people were used to spot
camouflage in world war
ii um because they are less sensitive to
color more sensitive to pattern that's
definitely i don't have red green color
blindness i've got a different color
blindness but
that's definitely something always got
to do it differently
yeah but you know i do
find whether it is downstream of that or
not i do find that there are certain
things
where color is distracting and pattern
is what you're after
that i'm pretty good at you know
spotting bat tents for example i was
very good at
um i've been questioning not so much
about rvs you weren't as good at that
no bad campers um
yeah but uh but anyway yes
i know it's a cliche but neurodiversity
has
intrinsic value which doesn't mean that
every variant has value but it does mean
that uh you don't want a population of
people who all have the same strengths
and weaknesses
exactly um so this is a comment not a
question so i'm gonna read it and then
find one last question but
um uh at the one hour fifteen minute
twenty second point of brett's dark
horse interview with garrett vandenbusch
it stressed that ivermectin should never
be used prophylactically
i don't remember that but i don't either
i go back and look at it
well this is a giant question but i'm
going to finish on it anyway
why are there a few species chicanas for
example in which females compete for
males
what makes them different yeah so
we do have a substantial portion
of our forthcoming book on mating
systems
which is the the core
theoretical basis uh um which your
question is stemming from so mating
systems
largely referring to population wide
do individual females tend to mate with
one or multiple males
and do individual males tend to mate
with one or multiple females the names
for the various mating systems you will
mostly be totally familiar with
um a one-to-one ratio on both sides is
monogamy
a free-for-all is called promiscuity
unless you're in humans in which case
somehow we're calling it polyamory now
although there will be people who argue
it's not a free-for-all but
okay um and um then polygamy
is the umbrella term for um a skew in
terms of one sex tends to have multiple
partners and the other sex tends to have
a single partner
um polygyny being the one that is most
familiar where
males tend to monopol a single male will
tend to monopolize the reproductive
efforts of multiple females leaving lots
of males unmated
um polygini multiple females polyandry
is the opposite in which a single female
will tend to monopolize the reproductive
efforts of
lots of males leaving many females
unmated maybe although i've never
actually heard that part of it described
um and chicanas um in which females
compete for males is an example of
polyandry but you would also see female
competition for males
um in situations of monogamy so for
instance with people we
we have yes we have male male
competition and female choice in humans
but we also have female female
competition and male choice in humans
in chicanas it's just female female
competition and male choice there's very
little female choice in male male
competition
but that is all set up none of that goes
to explain why chicanas and phala ropes
and a few other um
[Music]
rare a few other rare species actually
engage in polyandry so first of all we
should say
uh in the first part of today's program
we
talked about uh john cooley and david
marshall
experts on uh cicadas
magic cicada in particular we also know
one of the world's leading experts on
chicanas specifically pheasant-tailed
chicanas which are polyandrus
and live in thailand hi laura if you're
watching
um so she was also we were in grad
school with
her at the same time yep we were all in
grad school together they were great
lunches we
got together and talked about stuff and
laura was in fact in our wedding so
yeah yep anyway so anyway the
uh i i i must say i have i'm gonna have
to dust off my
uh toolkit for thinking about polyandry
but the
key thing that i think yes i don't force
you to that
uh is yeah thank you
um but the key thing is the
limitation on parental effort right so
in the human examples the rare human
examples of human
populations that engage in polyandry and
in the case of chicanas what you have is
a situation and
in jakartanas it's key that we're
talking about birds
right because a female bird people won't
necessarily know that yeah right birds
can lay
a female bird can lay eggs in a bunch of
different nests and so if what's
limiting
is parental effort a female who can get
a bunch of males to each mind a nest can
lay eggs in them and so that system is
modular and flexible in a way
that mammalian systems typically aren't
so
the um the human cases
tend to be situations in which the
environments are extremely harsh and
therefore the effort
sufficient to raise offspring is not
manageable by a couple right so the
point is having extra females makes the
problem worse not better
having extra males results in there
being enough parental effort to raise
children in the harsh environment so
what typically happens
the males that marry a single female
tend to be brothers
why because that reduces the cost to
each of them
of the offspring being fathered by the
others since they are genetically 50
related so anyway there's
a lot to be said but in general the key
is going to be
there are rare circumstances surrounding
parental effort
that favor the evolution of polyandry
yeah
so one of the models and i just i
cheated i looked up one of my own slides
from my
my shorebird lecture where i gave a
teaser about the origins of polyandry
uh one of the things i'm reminded of is
actually we only know it from fish
fishy fish and birds uh interestingly
and that may just be that there's like
less sociality in general
in in the non-avian herbs um
but that's that's interesting so you
know at the first you sort of need male
care to evolve for
you know lots of reasons that it could
and if male
care then allows the female um to start
producing
more eggs than um she than a single
individual can take care of um then
then basically the you know both she and
more than one of possible mates could
win
um by her divvying up her repertoire of
effort among
multiple males so when you say fishy
fisher we talk uh
sea horses and pipefish i only have the
bird stuff here because this was
a lecture on shorebirds but
um all right that's my prediction yeah
um
all right um yeah yeah we can
always always glad to talk about mating
systems but maybe we should stop that
yep
maybe we should we should stop that now
um
well it's been a long
couple of episodes long and winding by a
long and widening podcast
so we will finish by uh imploring you
to subscribe to this and the clips
channel to
like the video to share it with people
um
in whatever way is uh is good
um and you know especially for these
these q and a's
the um the um the terrific guy that we
have who's working on the clips channel
with us
um really pulls out clips and gets them
out there
quickly if there are any particular q
a's that you are interested in
seeing clipped go ahead and email
darkhorse.moderator
gmail.com to send that request and our
mod will
send that on consider joining us at
either of our patreons
uh for uh monthly private q and a's on
mine
and monthly private conversations on
brett's
and um in the intervening week before we
see you next
make sure to love the people you are
with and eat good food and get outside
and if you can't be with the one you
love keep it in your pants until you get
home
i just think that's good
[Music]
you